[Music]  hi everybody i'm lauren zima on The  Bachelorette Rachael Lindsay's final  three men met her family  Peter was adored winner  [Music]  Eric was embraced if Rachel decided you  two were going to take that journey -  which could lead to marriage I feel  comfortable with that and Bryan was  critiqued my gut is telling me Bryan's a  charmer Peter asked Rachel's family if  he could have permission to date her  while Bryan and Eric asked for  permission for her hand in marriage  and it seems like Rachel's decision  might boil down to that engagement  versus boyfriend situation I am come  here today and come here to have a  boyfriend  I want a proposal the bachelorette  season finale airs August 7th on ABC so  who do you think that Rachel picks let  me know over on Twitter  [Music]  you